it's tough going for these army scouts
from Armenia as the heat and humidity of
the Siberian summer take hold just one
of more than 20 obstacles referees are
on hand to make sure no one takes
shortcuts as they fight it out for the
fastest time the army games is the
brainchild of the Russian military
dreamt up as tensions with the West
surged following Russia's 2014
annexation of Crimea it brings together
militaries from as unlikely
brothers-in-arms as Israel and Iran back
in Siberia the general in charge of this
round says all countries are welcome to
take part
we'd really like to see how
well-prepared the Americans are the
Germans the British the French it would
be really interesting and great to watch
but that's a question for our diplomats
our leadership to reach an agreement it
will happen someday and we'd love to see
them here this round of the competition
bring soldiers from Russia's ex-soviet
allies together with participants from
as far afield as China and Zimbabwe of
course there are some ugly differences
in terms of procedures and some of the
things but I'm is the same we still do
this the same things though in a
different environment how did the trip
okay
yes of course they're having a challenge
there but we are we are trying to get
some of the ways though talking is a
challenge but understanding is not that
difficult
the Russian team showing how it's done
crossing the imaginary front line and
taking over communications with almost
20 kilos on their backs for all the good
humor and talk of sportsmanship here in
Siberia the so-called NATO offense
behind me is a reminder that ties
between Russia and the West are at their
worst for more than 20 years these games
are about showing that Russia has
alternatives as well as friends and
allies around the world in the end it
was all smiles for the hosts as the
Russian team finished ahead of
second-place China with less than a
minute between them what's a lot less
certain is whether the general will get
his way and see American or German
troops here anytime soon